et c'est la délivrance pour lycéens de
terminale le bac c'est enfin terminé au
moins jusqu'aux résultats avec peut-être
les rattrapages les dernières épreuves
se sont déroulées aujourd'hui avec les
mathématiques pour les filières es et
les ailes
les scientifiques eux ont passé les
épreuves de biologie mais le répit sera
de courte durée les futurs bacheliers
doivent attendre le 5 juillet pour
connaître le verdict aujourd'hui le
stress n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
d'écouter ses élèves du lycée de
villargoix de guyancourt il était plutôt
confiant au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas d'andré on sait enfin
délivrer en fait j'ai pris mon temps
j'avais largement le temps de faire il
ya des questions dures
j'ai passé j'ai confiance en moi
j'espère qu'on va avoir une bonne
réponse et que je parle au rattrapage
parce que j'ai envie de profiter de mes
vacances et voilà j'ai passé les maths
ça franchement ça a été un je pense que
je m'en suis bien sorti et ben je
verrais bien mais là je suis confiante
là je rêvais pas trop le sens que je
vais parce que je me dis tu vas l'avoir
bon après si je n'ai pas ça va être
autre chose mais non franchement là c
est né le 5 ce sera un peu de stress
mais ça devrait aller